pour la has est bon ça commençait
bonjour bonjour bienvenue
bienvenue sur ma chaîne youtube voilà
s'appelle slash monsieur dream ok ça
marche aussi
alors va être en 100 alors peut-être que
vous regardez rediffusion c'est possible
tu regardes vers une vision également
sais pas s'il est possible quand on est
comme ça c'est en live mais aussi redit
ferrer n'est ce pas ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui je vais demander au plus
beau de venir d'un coup
j'abandonne le cas c'est une petite demi
heure ensemble et on va surtout
s'intéresser à ce très très gênant
s'intéresser à ceux ci je suis allé au
mois de mai au japon et j'ai ramené des
objets totalement débile que nous allons
essayer ensemble
merci mais ne savait rien de rien nous
ne savons rien tu l'as pas ouvert de
peterhansel du japon maintenant j'ai
juste ouvert ce matin j'ai vu un truc
j'ai pouffé de rire je veux faire c'est
vrai c'est tout ce que j'ai fais pas ça
va être
ils vont les découvrir en live et vous
allez découvrir aussi et je propose de
commencer maintenant en fait c'est pour
fêter tous les 11 millions d'abonnés
oui à bâle et de talonner je suis moi je
suis abonné depuis 30 ans voilà donc ça
c'est des gens bien et on est en fait en
live ça se voit pas mais depuis mon
smartphone parce que je suis dans le
futur j'espère je suis en 2018 est ce
que vous avez peut-être pour montrer le
trépied stella norman est un technicien
mais qu'il a mis aux voix impayés avec
un support de microbes aura lamerat et
on va casser tout de suite on va glisser
bien évidemment l'attention
ma réputation de lumière est en jeu
attends je suis faire ça comme ça et la
moyenne un niveau incroyable
il est vraiment très chanceux je me
répète j'ai peut-être mettre un petit
effet peut-être l'aider piatti d'épicés
fait également voilà on décide
d'appliquer ces super et je vais faire
voilà huit millimètres pointe un petit
bustier en fête techno filter bien sûr
alors à temps voilà souvenions cela ne
tienne mans bien on est juste un peu
monsieur réal à la mais il est du métier
les liégeois
alors nous allons démarrer cette petite
occasion d'ouvrir
non je me serais bien d'ailleurs
regardez ça est ce que est ce qu'on peut
faire maintenant c'est avec la tête
ailleurs depuis huit ans que je joue à
cache cache alors regarde pas messieurs
non plus michael avec pour commencer
attends moi je l'aï lavé de fait les
comptes et en finale l'équipe et qui
fait de la tu n'es rien des commentaires
au cas où on n'a jamais vu un mec et ans
créateur comme ça vient vite à un très
bon ça c'est si jean reyssier jean
langlais attention thématique thématique
le sport qui est une ferme historique
moyen pratique de
après patrick histoire alors c'est parti
on va commencer avec cet objet là je
regrette c'est la partie de ces tirs et
les braves français c'est la résistance
c'est comme le type pour les mains quand
tu vas voir une poignée à la fin et en
plus il y avait plusieurs sujets de
votre magasin avec une mille trucs et il
ya plusieurs difficultés
les pierres déjà les super fort ya
plusieurs couleurs plus de couleurs
pourtant des difficultés je te laisse
mourir
génial donc sur le japon c'est le bio
les autres alors on y va presque
commence je suis vraiment j'aurais dû me
dire j'ai dit avant il faut attendre en
matière avec ses patins voilà j'ai fait
attendre six mois avant de commencer ça
j'ai fait du sport ce matin j'étais
quand même j'ai fait dit content merci à
l'audition d'un live monde et travail
absolument personne dans la pièce de
robert et agir vraiment j'ai vu petit
peu dur labeur peu sera entièrement
réservé d'habitude attendent pour
l'instant personne ne le faire alors du
coup pas mais elles ne suffiront pas
c'est super grave asie et s'est
cependant c'est pas super mais c'est
super bizarre non
ouais ça j'ai peur face à wigan où si tu
te lâchent pas comme ça alors
alors il ya des petites figures c'est
quand même les petites figures affaire
aura et je propose que nous commencions
par celle ci ok dans son dos énorme il
faut la mettre dans son dos brian âmes
de foot ça doit les caméras au pétard
s'est passé dimanche passé itunes match
alors je sais pas d'où vous qu'est ce
que ça muscle mais en tout cas il ya des
trucs qui sait bien que ça parce qu'on
pense attrapez le jouet lui que tu vas
faire celle ci s'est elle parle monsieur
l'aserc avec les pelles et pointent vers
le bas
d'accord ok comme de cette manière donc
comme ça et gilles bonhomme c'est super
cher cela je stoppe là ok je te fais
vite te rassure je découvre tu sens que
ça brûle laquelle on a fait des fautes
et la dsi change pas grand chose qu'ils
ont fait des trucs qui se lâche très
facilement ils ont dit on va faire une
boule comme ça ça existe des traces a
glissé et fait roi en achète un autre à
ça en fait niccolo canepa japonais
débarrassez vous pouvez jouer dans ce
live professional et c'est dur je
laisserais agir sur les réseaux sociaux
alors il est quoi il égorge les
européens et les européens bien sûr
toutes les photos choc allez merci ea
aussi en outre une dernière attention
c'est con
ça une dernière où il faut être assis
comme on peut le voir juste là ouais je
comprends pas on dirait qu'ils remontent
un type de scooter
d'ailleurs je vais attention aussi le
trépied l'inter tutorat une jambe et on
tue mais au bout voilà est la plus
classe que vous savez qu est-ce que
c'est plutôt décevant
je fais plutôt des sorts à apa pop tuant
voulait jouer le jeu du hasard mais
c'est drôle de hasard
[Musique]
alors c'est la vache c'est quoi ça
qu'est ce qu'un pistolet à bière hockey
comme vous pouvez ne pas le dire il
s'est en fait c'est un chantage aux deux
mots qui n'ont qu'un pistolet beretta
1er gr étape une assemblée pistolet
étape 2 mètres de la bière dedans étape
3 s'enjailler on la bière à l'extérieur
attention en fait je crois ça c'est pas
à lui de faire de la mousse et de lewy
j'ai un fou tu peux faire la mousse ou
de la mer donc finalement pour ceux qui
aiment la mousse c'est à dire de
personnes en france vous mettra dix
jours sans que ça va être technique
attention quand même à ne pas reproduire
chez vous il ne faut pas jeter de la
bière sur les gens c'est c'est malvenu
non j'aime pas bien alors alors donc une
vierge filière mer attention bien à quel
coût il est juste avant ou juste avant
sa cohérence
j'ai acheter de la bière et comment ça
c'est dit c'est un peu de look j'ai
acheté du panache et leader price voilà
ne buvez pas d'alcool ses très belles
races ont été bien la gentillesse de
l'expérience avec des sites sa base et
de mousse pour l'expert je m'emballe
soit en est visiblement il ya encore le
scotch dessus de sa grâce c'est un homme
boxing de piste où la vierge
moi je vais réagir commenter en live
donc on fera très vite un l'alcool est
mauvais pour la santé tu as raison mon
qu on vous déconseille d'en boire pénis
d'accord je n'arrive pas à lire alors
salut c'est s'est arrêté de parler qui
aime bien les épinards sont prises moi
j'adore le film dont la forme et la
qualité de l'objet d'art et penser à un
joueur fantastique et bien sûr la notice
donc vous aussi si vous lisez le
japonais est libre alors ça c'est bien
beau mais ça va laisser finir non pas du
tout c'est fini il faut d'abord
commencer par les petits
on aura donc finir dans le genre en cinq
minutes un rendez vous tout à l'heure en
fait c'est quand même 200 événements
alors quand j'ai commencé commenté ces
carnets écoute pour l'instant la caq a
comme commentaire j'aime beaucoup ya
prout aussi un vrai florilège de la
d'élégance d'abord commencé alors voilà
on va utiliser ce type de panache et
parce que vous êtes amateurs ne se fait
pas chez vous donner les viewers je vais
d'ailleurs je pleurais je crois non pas
les mettre ça je louvre mais ça va être
un débouchage on dirait c'est d'abord le
capuchon ça faisait très longtemps que
j'avais vu un panache et waouh quel
bonheur [ __ ] je voulais qu'on sait que
son panache et c'est vraiment le moment
du panache et c'est maintenant on peut
le faire qu'un soda nous a dit un mec
que j'avais dont le palu le prénom tu as
raison c'est là que je vois que tu es
pertinent et perspicace haut niveau le
faire avec toutes les boissons du monde
y compris de l'absinthe à l'e mail
annonce essayer de le faire devant vous
ok la sacoche avait la lourde tâche tic
sa sympathique
ok ça normal
je suis un même le soir au quai jeudi
qu'il allait ferait exactement tu es
très intelligent et déjà un des petites
choses bien sûr et ensuite ensuite sauvé
oui d'accord je me comprendre qu'il faut
faire ça ici
ensuite faut mettre ça ici c'est ce que
je remets dans ma bouche je joue encore
un week-end à j'ai compris ok ça c'est
capuchon que tu vas se clipser sur la
bière qui m est d'accord ok piège et
ensuite le capuchon va ce clip scission
d'aperam ça et nous allons à ces fins
bien ouais voilà ça marche
d'accord
il dise un truc là je sens assez
horrible d'avoir des petites des petites
précisions
voyez tu peux rien dire attention ouah
ça on est pas loin n'est pas loin je me
permets de tenter une position une fois
que c'est sur la bière tu fais
exactement j'ai tenté j'ai tenté j'ai
osé
je rappelle que je le technicien des
missions et ça n'a l'air de pas trop
marché c'est horrible de liart des
matelas car la déception est ce que vous
pouvez pas m'atteindre si vous pouvez me
laisser gérer les régies s'il vous plaît
il ya d'autres il a pris l'objet de plus
chiant à monter les axes ta ta vie ta
main si qu'est-ce-qui bien chiant le
bien qu'ils pensent que lui squeeze
l'autre d'autres partout sur le tee
shirt
moi je pense que oui dans les quelques
minutes jamais jamais jamais jamais ses
blessures j'adore mes constats se
retourner ça va se voir votre nom
non mais c'est en vain que la tournée
c'est normal je vous dis donc le concert
du kid c'est normal et l'a ensuite tu
fais ça je vous trouve pas voulu que je
venais à toi si celle-ci sa samba mais
c'est que c'est pas censé la taille de
la bière qui est quelques millimètres en
moins que la taille du truc donc rien
quand on va retourner cette rue de
quatre mecs comme en mai cette merde
tellement à mettre cette mère de nathan
plus fort il ya un truc elle super
longtemps rien
comment ça tu à lui du japonais moi j'ai
vu je plais marqué leur temps ils disent
que ce pour quoi il est vraiment là pour
soi on est tendu tout leur disait
regarde ces maps et on va gérer ça ça
doit les cac dans le petit truc ça ouais
attend mais de la taxe c est ce qu on
peut estimer sa dette à des coûts
c'est un aveu d'échec
[Applaudissements]
oh attention c'est une plaie des bières
[Musique]
on a perdu mais on a réussi à garder ça
marche trop bien ça marche c'est une
fille de la mousse attention aux quais
et maintenant on va faire de la mousse 1
pourrait s'appuyer sur nos temps c'est
quoi ça je pense pour la mousse vasif
l'énorme for men on s'appelle la mouche
ou pas est-ce qu'on peut dire ça marche
pas du tout voilà maintenant le studio
totalement une flaque ce n'est que la
seconde pas d'acheter cet objet en
soirée 0 bien évidemment sa pierre s'il
vous plaît kenza pierre ok ça a bien à
terme ça vient rappeler si les gens
anciens abonnés peuvent venir faire un
peu le ménage
ils sont repartis abonnés utile s'est
réuni 9 h
oman bon ben alors non non non non ça
marche
visiblement pas fait qu'en tête froide
japonais c'est d'être un objet un peu
raciste citepa japonais il refuse de
fonctionner moi j'ai plus de plaisir
personnellement mais c'était mon
approche mais ça y est je trouve ça
encore plus dangereux dans un fait
actuellement savoir blindé le sol de
certains mutins la pire idée de robes du
soir
bon voilà c'est ça allait voter ni objet
au hasard hier trousers stadium
vous pouvez acheter bien évidemment au
japon différentes hambourg allez je fais
moi je le fais avec
[Musique]
puisque la bière en [ __ ] mais arrêtez
je sais pas du tout comment ça
fonctionnait voici un truc qui permet de
de faire monter des oeufs en neige
ok ça ira d eux
j'étais obligé de traits que judith
humour ça bon assez du monde est morte
parce qu'elle coup je suis hyper fort
généreuse et demande d'associer la
tension les [ __ ] très compliqué les
oeufs et attention il ya un scandale
sanitaire
c'est vrai lien avec les républicains
espèrent ils sont et son petit ont péri
mais tout ça va ils sont périmés mais
bientôt on peut le faire vu buteur
n'avait pas fait et je charge de leur
faire des éléments déjà déjà c'est très
mignon faire un petit screen émettre sur
les avons regardés bien c'est pour faire
des idées des omelettes et baisse comme
ça voyez avec écrit love
oui il ya le voilà il faut mettre l'oeuf
là dedans et ensuite tu te rendes comme
un comme un bâtard franchement compliqué
et ensuite ça transforme sa non on
n'irait pas voter s'il vous plaît
vraiment comparé la taille des notices
qui fait vraiment la taille de mon buste
en 1902 dans on referme l'arrière du
crâne du poussin on met la petite
manivelle à charge l'impression d'être
décevant de bonnes occasions butant sur
d'autres actifs
en fait tu mets tout d'en bas ça c'est
par le jeune de l'homme j'avoue là
j'aurais directement et attendait une
petite manivelle cacher on en voit juste
ici elle est très important versé où
elle joue à la dose pour que alors la
manivelle très malin comme entrer quand
même vous adorez la cuisine vous êtes
tous abonnés à une chaîne de cuisine
regardez l'offre tongs là dedans et en
fait avec la petite manivelle
il n'y a que le blanc qui tombe et le
hall où ans georges reste à la hauteur
du poussant qu'est ce que c'est assez
fort mais ça n'a pas envie de tester en
vrai on a envie de tester
moi je vous dis un truc j'ai carrément
envie de séparer les eaux vraiment gros
plans pour que tout le monde profite
cette aventure composée de kc avec un
objet j'ai l'impression qu'on cuisine en
coupe et ça tourne mal merci grâce et la
nation attend attend je préfère jouer
des titres comme ça je m'approche hockey
vas-y tu en fais le plus là parce que
j'aime bien que ouais
[Musique]
attendre dans le chan ok d'autres est-ce
que vous avez aimé cette action et voilà
ces cas-là [ __ ] les mecs ne savent pas
cuisiner par c'est très simple moi ça va
vraiment être du groupe landreau contre
les gens et que tout le monde profite de
ce spectacle allez merci à tous noirs
moi je veux casser c'est bon les
internautes vont bien a plu au plus haut
c'est bon on attend c'est bien séparées
par contre c'est par terre les services
sont déjà par terre appellent pas
d'argent il est passé il cassé d'une
heure maintenant elle est cassée bien
c'est raté
mais qu'est ce qui est cassé mais tout
est en très bas tout est rentré dedans
pour commencer c'est un scandale je
devais me montrer j'ai vraiment vert or
j'aimerais montrer ce qui se passe à
noter c'est dégueulasse pas si c'est
abominable attaché mais japonais fallait
faire plus à sa part plus pratique à
dijon c'est plus ou moins vides et on
recommence diop c'est bon alors du coup
l'image pense je me suis pris la
l'abysse la chatte or excusez moi c'est
une anecdote annuler allez c'est parti
c'est parti pour quelques uns raté par
attend il faut vraiment que tu mettes
vers moi et ensuite on leur montre là où
c'est très beau très charismatique
regardez le fait là le jaune le blanc
est là tout doucement j'ouvre attend
mais
j'arrive à intervenir tout l'ouest et
j'arrête pas en fait et l'allemand nico
sachant qu'on va pas faire la cuisine à
faire donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui marche c'est très beau les deux
jaunes d'oeuf sont séparés du blanc et
le blanc des samba mélangé à du vieux
jeu on va sans dire effectivement c'est
la chaîne cyprien l'afr mais je peux
tourner la manivelle à tavannes la
notice a dit s'attendre à ce que la
plaçant le blanc est en bas c'est
forcément tous ordres de ben il faut
tourner la manivelle comme prévu fait
logique et le jaune allez je te laisse
l'honneur le tour n'est pas fini leur
trop tard je les fais purée je suis
vraiment il ya main et c'est culte la
chatte or elle s'est trouvé ça marche on
alors maintenant on va y aller 2 1 on va
faire comme un prophète comme les gros
bourrins tu es prêt il faut de la force
moi je propose de voler cette légende
notes sont coincés là ouais tu peux les
libérer à tout est fait dans les centres
des villes ils monteront pas s'emballer
que le frère tu es sûr que le jury est
ce que ça va vraiment monter
[Applaudissements]
on en est large et sur celles d'in salah
ça tourne mal
d'accord c'est beaucoup quoi ça monte ou
pas fring wintergreen ça a marché mais
sinon c'est les branches et inventer
comme vous voyez sont fait entendre à
tanger real est prêt syndiqué et attends
j'ai peur la tête des débats des jeux de
m'aider il ya 1 3 ça veut dire trois
minutes faut tourner rien à troyes il
faut être là trois mois il faut il ya
marqué ya marque 1 1 1 3 3 persos sur
l'étape 3 c'est plus heureux encore eh
ben ça fait le tri belge attend voudrait
continuer moi je vais moulinet a put
alors quel est votre objet préféré
jusqu'à présent plutôt le poussin pour
les plus tôt le spermatozoïde siamois le
spermatozoïde siamois que le sport légal
g l'acteur gérard déguisements et je
propose qu'on fasse un petit chiffon me
pour savoir qui
le barrage en train de voler les mecs
alors non seulement choisir le jeu
peut-être suis-je repères et j'avais dit
que j'avais une thématique qui ne te
fatigue pas oui l'état disent tu vois
c'est esporte je sors ça va manger des
oeufs
tu sais ouais il compte d'ailleurs je
pratique sur le prof j'ai trouvé l'objet
j'ai rêvé de l'autre géant nex et j'ai
gagné sept jours à tonnerre je crois que
c'est monté mais non pas du tout alors
c'est comme ça c'est un peu de travers
c'est un clavier apple
alors qu'est ce que c'est la table bon
je pense à un hoverboard la vendrai mais
sans roues c'est un szpiner géant gratin
faciale fitness mais pour le savoir
le mot faisait là cristiano ronaldo a
fait la promotion de trucs logement qui
me tester moi ok j'adore alors c'est
parti
[ __ ] c'est stylé en tout cas c'est bon
ça coûte très cher et c'était très dur à
trouver un drôle que j'ai fait plusieurs
états à trouver
je laisse tomber un don quichotte de
shinjuku dit un design
alors maintenant saviez vous que mais la
même source de rangement c'est un
boomerang c'est un drône c'est quoi on
ne peut rien de sert à quoi il utilise
dans la plupart oui je sais qu est ce qu
il faut enlever ça
pour l'instant pourquoi sammour alors il
ya une notice angry men japon voilà un
salon vous pressent que c'est pas du
sipal est ce que ça va c'est sans ses
muscles et ces zones là donc les joues
les joues et les joues au n'ont jamais
dû faire ça
kaka sera jamais acceptée dans la cas
est ce que je peux vous et je remettrai
les parties lisant la description je
voudrais le lire de la pudeur de hockey
alors alors alors le même monsieur
millions non non non c'est une vidéo
pour toi et voilà non mais cela on était
tous team [ __ ] faut vraiment se faire
mais de faire le même ils ont fait
explique ça s'enlève pourquoi ruraux et
que ta mère absolument la tutoie qu'on
voit bien les deux extrémités de doubler
alors ils disent il faut mettre dans sa
bouche le truc est fermée avec la petite
encoche aussi pour fermer les dents
dessus comme ça si je l'a rachetée
ensuite ils disent quand vous êtes prêts
enfin raconte comment feront ils disent
laisser laisser tourner comme ça pendant
30 secondes augmenté la cadence dans ma
tête des documents attendez attendez
ça change et ça c'est beau c'est grand
schéma sera d'habitat quoi comme
notamment d'autres emboîtent notre
ceinture et ça m'a tout simplement exclu
au barème la bouche est-ce que ça me
saoule quoi lasser un muscle clairement
cette partie là je suis lâche comme
mousse coulisses à peu près la taille
n'est pas tant celui ci peut le faire
dans lequel on attendait maintenant
deuxième question sur cet objet selon
vous hassani que le pâle et son goût
après ça tu essayais bonsoir c'est quoi
cette fois cédé pour un nom génial lutin
mm et le poids maximal à s'est passé
lors je ne l'avais cran plus haut la
main sur un poids très léger
ah ouais c'est trop mignon j'adore les
suivent allez bon vous voyez pas
différence mais cela est fait il fait
celle de gilot et les mets de 16 kilos
mais on doit ça dans la bouche il fait
ça en jouant au foot
cet état car oui du cas pour moi un peu
ils ont donc toi moi non braverman vol
pour moi ça marche
imagina t de squeeze la somme le pas de
couleur mais je dois me mettre nue mais
si la chaire au japon il se met
forcément venus avec des colons mais toi
tu as juste à mettre la halle à la
culotte
merci quand j'ai vu ce truc là dans le
magasin j'ai fait je dois acheter de
manière immédiate quatre secondes plus
tard c'était acheter on parle de quel
animal actuellement c'est simple et plus
sûr un signe de plus sur un mois ce que
tenir la tête
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que vraiment je tiens
le sexe sexe
lorsqu'elle s'en forme de peluche bon et
là il ya tout cas mettre au dessus de
moi j'aime bien tomber sur des objets
attends je vais m'en pose de combiner
ces objets avec celui de jardinage à
tanger pas je devais aller à une
élection on va sentir
j'en peux plus
j'en veux plus mise au point s'est
offert lundi
de ma tâche est un costume à à personne
commence à ressembler à deux français
normalement si tu veux vraiment officiel
pour le faire complètement secrètement
marc goua choix français chevaux à
chacun de stopper le pas dans ses allées
en soir au quai attention mauvais point
pour normal tu vas devoir forcer je vous
laisse découvrir que vous le
reconnaissez ou par inf'ogm stage ici
teddy plomberie c'est un président qui a
dit qu'il ya eu des violences des deux
côtés des deux côtés la bonne a dit le
pr bonnet masque de donald pu me
[Musique]
évidemment mange des juges étaient
obligés d'aller faire cette tête là je
le ferai avec le doigt alors tiens ça tu
es fatigué l'onu
ces drames ont emmené ces points ont été
sur cet amas ce que tu peux porter même
quand il ne pas tu ne partage pas les
opinions politiques
donald trump je le dis comme ça parce
que vaslui du monde mais il n a pas les
bons choix
tout d'abord des bons jeux vous plaît
commentant un bon milieu tombe bien dans
la victoire
je pense qu'on est parvenu tout est
génial et je la pourquoi c'est moi qui
prends tout dans la gueule attention
cartes mises en situation bien sûr ces
prêts ouais voilà ces petits mots je
suis battu jusqu'au pic élections avec
un saint et humaine va prendre deux
canettes avec
m acte i s qui ouvre ses qui peut se du
coup je fonde rétracter et il ya un truc
pour seul accroché vraiment comme si tu
pouvais le sortir de manière sage hop là
whaou
ce qui va obliger qui sont forcément
humiliant s'avérer un objet qui te met
en valeur alors là les gars pourraient
terminer sur deux petits trucs ça va me
les coûts qui sont pas mal du tout alors
michael en traction fait chaud la
consigne ça
s'il ya des gens qui parlent japonais on
va le tester tout à l'heure et vous avez
essayé de dominer dans les commentaires
de deviner ce que c'est
c'est en live donc vous essayez de
deviner apprécions tout le monde envie
de gaulle ça n'est ce pas qu'est ce qui
est difficile c'est ça c'est non a mis
d'accord ça parce que ça va ces deux
collants qu'on met sur la tête moi alors
les du jeu aurait déjà prononcé du jeu
japonais
voilà un boulot tu as not double cd
c'est le premier qui je pense a tant qui
meurt s'il ya un mois
accroche-toi qu'il réalise un crochet
[ __ ] sluc a dû jouer allez vas-y que
je te laisse choisir le bon coup je veux
bien debout et moi je fais larbitre sais
pas si c'est une baston c'est le premier
qui arrive d'ailleurs en qu'est ce que
c'est dur en fait non non et non il faut
le mettre
vous avez le et à l'aube où donc est ce
que tu fais un braquage comme ça on voit
ça tenait bon ça c'est pas très cher
c'est vraiment qu'elle est bien racontée
maintenant il faut essayer de faire
parce que tu que l'on choisit tirs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils vont vraiment cet objet ces deux
couleurs h voilà bah moi c'est
permettant toutes les sympathies passer
pour aller avec ça s'appelle des
lunettes de fainéants lazy glasses part
c'est génial ça quand tu n'as pas envie
de regarder c'est pour lire pour lire
mais que c'est embêtant mais c'est trop
bien mais sa route gelée bus a sauté les
annonces de merde à facebook c'est vrai
j'aime le vieux débat il savait retour
du japon
génial moi je te devinette donc c'est
drôle s'il ya des mecs qui font ça
vraiment au premier degré pas évident
que cet objet sur le soir il est vrai
qu'on est un savant génial je peux bien
mais j'étais un peu ces mêmes oreilles à
la télé ça marche du coup je peux être
allongée comme ça qu'est ce que vous
voyez ces [ __ ] j'ai l'honneur
attention ça va être génial
or je vois clairement le sol la tempête
un jeune homme aimant la salle
l'histoire la tête la tête à fond est
rien comment ça va les filles attends je
peux parler que de faire un petit jeu ah
non mais c'est très bien de marché
moyenne taille
ces chaleurs et tu vois bien ça moi
aussi
là je vois la lys à papa je vois tes
doigts botmeur et je vois attention on
va terminer attrapant la captation je
peux tester une rechute en arrière
tester mais non mais je viens de voir
est ce que dans les commentaires des
gens trouvaient plus mais c'est faux
obligé il y à des fonds des messages
allemands mais après ça doit bien non
mais j'aimerais que dans un jeu vidéo en
anglais mais c'est fou attends je vais
voir tout non personne n'à à trouver
quel est cet objet non je sais pas
combien en a mais je fais un truc
d'accord je leur exclusion qui fut
ultimement on va juste et alors non
c'est un narcissique
d'accord c'est dur c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut emmener un abricotier aucune
idée à potes non c'est pas c'est un
homme bien
enak irakiens dont deux non c'est pas
pour sauver les poils du nez c'est bien
pour le nez maintenant je vais vous
montrer comment ça marche pardon dans le
dos d'ailleurs c'est à dire et on fait
donc c'est à dire que si ça se met alors
le nasdaq est en fait non c'est quand tu
es dans le lit alors avoir le même plus
pointus ok pour avoir un et bien
pointues par contre ça libère dangereux
j'ai peur que ça fait chier sarel à
plusieurs comme ça je pouvais essayer 5
milliards ça va être incroyable c'est
drôle ça mais mais cambrai cet objet est
drôle mais il est très utile en fait
franchir à grenay ici tout le monde
avant nasa il ya tout cas taiwo om
plutôt calme sur vous mais moi je vais
prendre moi je suis plutôt je vais
prendre moi je prends
d'autres exemples montrent assez xxl
s'est passé c'est pour mettre à temps et
y apparaît ça y'a sxs ok d'accord a
quant à elle bondi feu des critiques
ça se met dans le nasale nom pourri
savoir un des pointus ok c'est
naturellement mais écoute du hockey dix
huit candidats devant le colombien
alors je vous montre l'artiste aux
internautes
ça se met d'angle dans la narine et
après ça va s'enlever avec une petite
tige
on va voir si ça s'enlève à l'hôpital en
fait aux urgences voici mon est
actuellement sous mais ok voilà il est
de manière tout à fait nasa guewel et
maps et à temps mais ça très laid 17le
c'est temporaire château énormément
parce qu'on tient vite j'ai trop peur
c'est horrible je me sens tellement
rentrée mais voilà c'est pas du tout
impressionnant attend un [ __ ] c'est
rentré au cerveau non un petit chez
désolé je suis désolé les gars c'est
dégueulasse voilà ce qui est bien c'est
que tout - c'est discret voile
actuellement je suis en savoir nez
pointu là
es16 en fait c'est fait pour des nez de
d'asiatiques qui sont assez bons relance
le fil rouge grâce à ça c'était pour
écarter des narines en fait c'était pour
allonger ça fait comme ça je t'assure
j'ai compris j'ai compris tu vas bien
que je laisse ça changerait mais les
généraux petit ça change et je vais
essayer le gixel ok mais c'est lui qui
s'est déjà bien le truc hockey et
attention c'est un bonheur peut-être que
vous voyez mondiale désormais il sera
peut-être un peu plus grand juste après
sa 6ème à a pas mal je pense qu'il ya
une amélioration la dune a annoncé voilà
c'est pas mal c'est de man s'est très
mal même est-ce que c'est douloureux
ah ah oui [ __ ] ça l'avant sympa ah oui
un petit peu en veine géologique est un
peu chier c'est pas mal ça oh mon dieu
ça marche trop bien à qui c'est vrai
mais à laquelle sa main flagrante son
horrible j'ai l'impression d'avoir
ramené kilos en trop [ __ ] t'es bon
pablo dire qu'on est là attention parce
qu'ils font des choses petit crochet
pour pouvoir sans lever le truc là mais
tu me fallait savoir quand je mets les
gros doigts dans le nez pour retirer mon
attention
je me demande si des jeunes ont-ils des
gens le le m c'est hyper lourd et ya
quoi [ __ ] sévèrement pull back wac et
l'est pas c'est juste un truc qui se
tient à un moment avec enter enrhumé oui
c'est dégueulasse aux jeunes voient un
commentaire effectivement ne pas faire
apparemment être plus de 100000
visionnaire mais vous avez
n'achetez pas du tout ces objets c'est
très dangereux pour la santé nous je
pense que ça peut être très grave et et
malheureusement c'est la fin du live au
maximum à aaa c'est décevant a terminé
sur un nul décevant c'est grâce est un
jeu de cartes avec des billets c'est
plutôt nul et on finit en bouquet
attendra finalement attendre magique je
fais régulièrement bataille kas mickey
est beau l ai pas dégueulasse un beau
des billets alors ça pour ça vaut le
l'achat ou pas ça vaut le détour avec
attendrissement 700 tire les cartes joue
de la basse - celle ci est d'améliorer
plus tard musique mais pourquoi ces
lignes on attaque on perd toute approche
du truc approche toi bien attention
d'ailleurs cette fois il n'y a rien mais
en un clin d'oeil webcast étape 1
celui-ci est dans ma poche au total ces
six attentats à tan rouge par an en mai
et des retrouvailles jour elle tomber
merci beaucoup merci messieurs l'arrière
merci les copains d'arrêter les 11
millions d'abonnés merci beaucoup mais
tu es à un pouce en l'air abonnez vous
parler autour de vous de cette chaîne
incroyable qui est ma chaîne youtube et
moi je vous dis à très très vite sur
internet
ababord voir un deuxième appareil
arrêtez arrêtez merde